c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
non c'est vrai que c'est bon c'est vrai
je t'assure
mon pire souvenir de vacances c'est une
croisière enfin croisière un ferry en
grèce pour à l'est d'athènes jusque dans
les îles je crois que c'était les
sporades du nord j'étais malade je me
suis sentie mal j'ai voulu savoir où
étaient les toilettes j'ai donc été dans
le poste de commandant de l'équipage et
j'ai vomi sur tout l'équipage
il s'en rappellent encore septet en 1988
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir de vacances ça se
passe à hawaï pourquoi hawaï
vous connaissez la série hawaii 5-0
avant c'était hawaï police d'état
quand on était plus jeunes un mois et
j'adorais cette série je suis allé à
hawaï pour voir les policiers parce que
je pensais qu'ils existaient réellement
et donc j'ai réussi à aller dans une
voiture de police à white comme si
j'étais aloi et 5 0 j'ai adoré ça en a
sillonné honolulu et où je me rappelle
encore génial ça c'est la vraie vie
[Musique]